Apple's much-anticipated smart speaker
will be available in stores tomorrow the
home pod is priced at $349 this high-end
speaker is designed to work with an
apple musics of subscription and iTunes
Apple's digital assistant that Siri is
also available on the home pod a recent
report suggests by the end of this year
consumers will use more than five
billion devices featuring digital
assistants nearly three billion more
will be added by 2021 Dan Ackerman from
our partners at C net is here to discuss
hey Dan Ackerman you have one of these
in your house I do not have one of these
yet I have a couple of echos and a few
other devices so I have a lot of smart
assistant that's what I mean you have a
digital assistant in your right and they
have that big number it's like it's
built into every phone now so anyone who
has a phone basically has a smart
assistant so 349 seems like a pricey
pricey a big price to pay for this is it
worth it especially when you consider
the device that a lot of people have the
Amazon echo or the echo dot that's like
$99 $50 so everyone who's tried this out
and we tested one at our smart home
testing facility down in Kentucky and
our audio experts said it sounded
fantastic there's really a great amazing
sounding speaker as you would expect a
three hundred and fifty dollars single
speaker to be it better sound great and
it does but it but in that far end of
the spectrum compared to the smart home
devices that people have been buying for
the last year or two
is there a competitive advantage on the
smart phone part I mean is the series
say something special or new or tell you
you look wonderful or it's not the same
basic Siri built in that you have built
into your phone so if you like that
phone experience it's very similar
some people prefer Alexa which is the
Amazonas system some people for the
Google assistant which is built into
Android phones and the Google home which
is Google's version of that smart
speaker device new york times review
called Siri on the home pod
embarrassingly inadequate adding Sirius
sorely lacking in capabilities compared
with Amazon's Alexa and Google's
assistant I think that will affect sales
yeah that's really that's really the
issue with these smart speakers it
doesn't sound like a good endorsement
yeah
telling you how to find this we've been
making fun of Siri for years and it's
gotten better but it's not quite at the
same level as a Lex or the Google
assistant in kind of a lot of this
conversational back-and-forth stuff you
want to do and these companies take
these products they put them on a
spectrum I think there's this the smart
end of the smart speaker on one side and
there's the speaker end on the other and
Amazon and Google have said oh let's
make it smart that's the main thing and
Apple is saying let's make it a speaker
first and the smart stuff second what do
you want do they want the speaker or do
they want the information I think a lot
of people the early adopters one of the
smart stuff because that was new and
different you could always get a good
sounding speaker at home but for Apple
customers they're very locked into that
ecosystem they have an iPhone they maybe
they have an Apple music subscription
which is ten dollars a month instead of
Spotify this is a device that's really
built for people who already have that
or want to have that all at all in all a
police I like I had that ue boom and the
other stuff that Apple sells and I
really like those yeah that's great but
if you have Spotify or you like use
another music service this device
doesn't work natively with that you can
beam to it from your phone using airplay
but it's not the same as using the voice
commands which I think everybody loves
about these you go play this artist play
the song played this genre that kind of
works for me because I use my Apple
music a lot it would work it would work
for me what does it have to be here
what's the next frontier on the
assistant part like what are we all
gonna get soon that's gonna make our
lives really amazing I think we're
getting to the point now especially on
the Amazon and the Google side where we
have multi-user versions where everyone
in the house through voice recognition
it knows who you are and this is
something the home pod actually doesn't
do yet but the other ones do and I'm
sure it'll come everywhere eventually
where it can tell who's talking to it
and give you personalized feedback in
information your calendar your music
tapes
what you're interested in just by
listening to your voice all right Dan
thanks thank you